every dollar not come is a whole lot
more than us just launching a software
tool to help you fix and run your budget
it is the key core element to you
winning with money and we've been able
to put a business model together where
we can give it to you for free and so
there's just this massive amount of data
massive amount of anecdotal
conversations we've had think about the
people that call in with their debt free
screams how many of them say when I ask
them what the secret to getting out of
debt is how many of them say I'm unified
with my spouse and I have a written
gameplan
that's just mammoth it's so huge there's
something about telling your money what
to do instead of wondering where it went
like John Maxwell says a budget is that
causes you to move with your money when
you start doing a written plan all your
money you'll feel like you got a raise
every time my friend Zig Ziglar used to
say if you aim at nothing you'll hit it
every time and most people are aiming at
nothing with their money and
consequently they're retiring broke that
are not generous they don't have a game
plan they're not unified with their
spouse because they're not aiming at
anything guys you got to do this you got
to start doing this written gameplan
it's not optional and an easy free way
to do it yes I'm gonna give you an ad
because I believe it works more than
anything we've done in a long long time
every dollar calm you're gonna see
results I mean literally that night the
night you sit down and do this with your
spouse you're gonna feel this release of
oh my god even though we've got a mess
I'm happening to the mess instead of
being overwhelmed by the mess or I'm
making a lot of money and it's time for
me to be a grown-up and take control of
it and do good things for my family and
good things with others of it instead of
just looking up and going crud we've
made 150,000 bucks we got nothing to
show for it that's just immature and
ridiculous and a whole sector of our
culture is immature or did
it's time people it's time for
Renaissance in the art of personal
finance this matters start doing a
written game plan where every dollar has
a name before the month begins do it on
paper do it on a spreadsheet use someone
else's tool use every dollar calm but
for goodness sakes do it every month
before the month begins for the rest of
your life give every dollar an
assignment